Game of Thrones’ Night King isn't a character
known for his friendly face and adorable smile,
and the extra-weird look he gave Bran Stark
during the Battle of Winterfell had everyone
wondering what was going on in his frosty
brain.
Here's what was really going on during that
eerie exchange.
You probably remember how the scene went down:
Bran sat beneath the weirwood tree in the
godswood of Winterfell, awaiting the Night
King's arrival.
When the icy villain finally approached, he
ambled toward the youngest living Stark man
before stopping and staring into his eyes
with an eerie look on his face, an expression
most fans took as clear intent to kill Bran,
a.k.a the Three-Eyed Raven.
According to the Night King himself, Slovakian
stuntman Vladimír Furdík, that isn't exactly
what was going on in his own head.
Furdík recently revealed to Vulture the real
reason why the Night King looked at Bran like
he wanted to turn his insides to icicles.
As it turns out, the Night King’s glowering
glare at Bran wasn’t solely motivated by
a desire to kill an enemy.
In actuality, the strange look he gave Bran
was mostly the result of some interesting
direction Furdík got ahead of shooting the
scene.
The director of the Battle of Winterfell episode,
Miguel Sapochnik, instructed Furdík to walk
toward Bran Stark actor Isaac Hempstead Wright
and imagine him as a cake that he desperately
wanted to eat.
Kind of weird, right?
When Furdík breaks it down, though, it’s
actually not the oddest direction in the world,
and he was clear in the interview that he
considers Sapochnik a, quote, “great director,”
who gave him “very good direction.”
The actor explained,
“I remember a couple of times when I did
the walk, and I go for my target, which was
Bran, and he said, 'Bran, he is not man.
He is a cake.
And you would like to eat this cake.
And I would like to see you acting, you're
walking to him, you're walking like you're
looking for that cake, which is waiting for
you under the tree.'"
Furdik continued to elaborate on the direction,
saying,
"Adults never run for the cake.
They walk.
You can see from an [adult's] body, they're
going for a cake from grandmom, and they're
looking forward to eating this cake.
When I walk, you can see what Miguel said:
'Don't be a soldier.
No.
Just walk, confident.
There's a cake.'"
"Lemon cake’s my favorite."
"So we’ve been told."
Furdík also shared that he’s still not
sure that the Night King even wanted to kill
Bran in the first place.
He said to Vulture,
"Look, we think he's going to kill Bran, but
who knows if he's going to kill him?
He doesn't rush.
Maybe he had different [plans].
Maybe he wanted to do something else.
You know?
Then [Arya Stark] kills him.
But maybe he was gonna show them, 'No, no,
no, wait, I'm here for something else!'"
Just as Furdík received instruction on how
the Night King should look at Bran during
the tense sequence, Hempstead Wright also
spoke at length with director Sapochnik to
decide the way Bran should look back at the
Night King.
The 20-year-old actor revealed to The New
York Times that he and Sapochnik, quote, "came
up with this idea that the look Bran gives
the Night King is one of pity."
Hempstead Wright further explained,
"Bran saw the creation of the Night King,
or the first White Walker, or whatever.
He realizes that he was once just a normal
guy who was forcibly strapped to a tree, and
had a piece of dragonglass plunged in his
heart...He didn't ask to become this raving,
crazy ice killer…So we tried to get a moment
where Bran is feeling sorry for him.
Bran is looking at this ancient being who
didn't want to become this murderer, but is."
While Hempstead Wright acknowledged that the
Night King did have it out for the Three-Eyed
Raven, he offered another explanation as to
why he stopped to look at Bran with that haunting
look on this face:
"The reason the Night King takes so long is
that he's been programmed to destroy the Three-Eyed
Raven from the moment he was created, so he's
taking a moment to savor it."
That pause wound up costing the Night King
everything, as it opened up a window for Arya
to attack and kill him, plus destroy his pack
of White Walkers and wights in the process.
"Just when you think that Jon Snow’s going
to be the hero, again, we realize, that Arya
appears through the mist."
In the end, the Night King didn't get to have
his cake or eat it, and the plants that sprouted
through the snow during the closing moments
of the Game of Thrones series finale seem
to suggest that he never will.
Winter is over, and the Night King is dead.
Good job, team, you all deserve a snack for
this one.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.